♫ 1, 2, 3, Think fast! ♫
-All right, now --
That was a good theme song
right there.
[ Laughter ]
Here´s how it works --
We´re gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
One person asks the questions.
The other person
has to answer each question
as soon as it´s asked,
and I mean immediately.
-Okay.
-Yep.
It doesn´t matter
if the answer´s right or wrong,
just has to be
the very first thing
that pops in your head.
-Okay.
-Will, because you´re the guest,
I´ll read the questions first,
and you´ll answer them.
Are you ready for this?
-Yes, I am.
-Here we go.
♫♫
[ Clock ticking ]
Why were you late?
-I was curling my hair.
[ Laughter ]
-How do you make bananas?
-Growing them.
-Who is Mr. Feldman?
-Next door neighbor.
-What does Santa Claus do
when he´s mad?
-Smokes a pipe.
[ Laughter ]
-What´s a cool greeting?
-He-ey!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-Fantastic. That´s correct.
That´s correct.
You answered
all those correctly.
-Oh, great.
-He-ey!
All right, now --
now it´s my turn.
Whenever you´re ready,
take the card
and ask me the questions.
-Okay.
♫♫
What should I buy online?
-Everything.
-Where is Eric?
-On the stairs!
[ Laughter ]
-What´s it called
when two ducks kiss.
-Squacking.
[ Laughter ]
-When is Thursday?
-Wednesday.
[ Laughter ]
-Who do --
Why do you love me?
-´Cause you´re cuddly.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-You got them all right.
-I did get them
all right, as well?
-I got it wrong.
I said, "Who do you love me?"
"Who do you love me?"
-Who do you love me?
Yeah, Hootie loves me.
-Yeah.
-That´s what I yell at the
Hootie and the Blowfish concert.
[ Laughter ]
All right, now it´s time
for the final round,
and this round, we´ll both --
-Wednesday is Thursday?
-Well, yeah.
Thursday´s Wednesday.
-Okay, okay.
-Yeah.
For this round,
we´re gonna both pick up a card.
Same set of questions,
and we´ll ask and answer them
one at a time,
going back and forth, okay?
-And who asks first?
-I will start.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
♫♫
What´s the worst thing
about Halloween?
-Candy comatose.
[ Laughter ]
Rhyme two words.
-Don´t and mon´t.
[ Laughter ]
Where is the Olive Garden?
-In Italy.
[ Laughter ]
-What´s for dessert?
-Crunches.
John, Paul, George,
Ringo and...?
-Uh, Paul.
John.
[ Laughter ]
Why did you quit ballet?
-Because it´s
too time-consuming.
[ Laughter ]
What is not a curse word?
-Not a curse word.
How long do you spend
combing your hair every day?
-Two to three hours.
"Home Alone"
was originally called what?
-"Home With People."
[ Laughter ]
Tell me a secret.
-I´m -- I´m bouncing.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Yeah, there you go.
That´s the secret.
-We did it.
-Yeah, we did it.
[ Ding! ]
I couldn´t get that last one.
"Home With People."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It didn´t test well.
-It didn´t test well.
"Home Alone" was better.
"Home With People",
yeah, wasn´t good.
That was "Think Fast!"
with Will Forte, everybody.